here's all the stuff I've been using
let's see how it compares to my old
skincare routine it's Michelle of La
muffin Beauty science chemistry PhD
cosmetic chemist and person who really
doesn't talk that much about her
skincare routine for a skincare
influencer with all this talk of skin
cycling it made me think about my
skincare routine which involves modifies
cycling I guess and I remembered I made
this video in July 2020 reacting to my
2019 skincare routine so today I'm going
to react to my old reaction video and
chat about what I'm still using what's
changed and whether or not I still agree
with what I said like subscribe
notification Bell so the problem with
doing a full reaction to that video is
that that video was already 26 bloody
minutes long so I'm going to be skipping
around a lot I don't like sharing my
routine that often because I'm testing
products and I don't want to endorse
something that I haven't fully tested
yet I agree with that last time and I
still agree with it now before I have an
opinion on a product I like to use it
consistently for a couple of weeks and
then I like to use it also on and off in
different conditions in different sorts
of weather in different parts of my
menstrual cycle when my Skin's irritated
when it's not just to get like a really
thorough idea of how the product
interacts with my skin and when it
really shines and when it doesn't so I
think it's tempting for people to see my
routine and try to copy it exactly my
Skin's knees aren't the same as another
person's Skin's needs you get to know
your skin and its needs then base a
routine on that and your budget and
product accessibility that's why the lab
muffin guide to basic skincare starts
with instructions on how to perform a
skin assessment you can't work out what
your skin needs if you're using products
that aren't right for your skin then
purling products suited to someone
else's skin on top you just can't yes I
still 100 agree with this I am a big fan
of purposeful deliberate conscious
skincare use even though those words
sound like really hippy-dippy it
actually stresses me out a bit when I
hear about products going viral and
selling out I really feel like skincare
just shouldn't be a fad and I hate that
skincare is heading towards or maybe
it's even there like a fast fashion
model where products and even Brands
aren't planning to stick around for even
a year I think it is fine and natural to
get bored of your products and want to
change things up every once in a while
but this sort of artificial marketing
driven over consumption is just not
sustainable and it's not good for your
skin or your wallet I think a lot of
skincare instagramers tend to share
their routines and it will be like 10
products and half of them will change
every single day I think it gives people
who are less experienced a misleading
idea of how many products should be in a
routine and how often you should be
changing them out I still agree with
this although I think social media has
moved it's gone from photos with 15
products to tick tocks that I like you
gotta try this product it completely
changed my skin everyone run out and buy
it now from the sorts of comments and
questions I get I feel like a lot of
people don't really know how to put
together a routine anymore it's a lot
more focused on individual training
products that might not actually make a
lot of sense put together so now on to
my personal routine my routine isn't
rigid I adapt it based on how my skin
feels that's still the case I will pick
products based on whether my Skin's
feeling tight dry what the weather is
like as well my top priorities are
anti-acne and anti-pigmentation that
hasn't changed I'm turning 32 this year
so young so I'm starting to see more
white hairs and wrinkles okay my skin
concerns have actually changed now with
acne I was off the pill in 2019 I
started again in early 2020. so now that
I've been on the pill consistently for
almost three years my hormonal breakouts
have died down a lot I'll get one deep
pimple on my chin every second month
sometimes I'll get a pimple like right
here because I put my head down during
pilates class and I'm pretty sure that
just yeah messed up that area but yeah
it's a lot more rare now with
pigmentation I mostly work from home in
an office that doesn't get much sunlight
plus I did a few rounds of picosure
laser treatments last year and with less
acne there's also less of that
post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation so
with pigment it's more about prevention
for me than treatment now which is
pretty much just my day routine with
sunscreen although we are heading into
summer now so the pigment situation
might change I do really like hiking my
wrinkles I don't think they've changed
that much I think the lack of sun and
that Pico shawl also help with that so
the bad side there's a pandemic so I
wear a 3M Aura mask a lot of the time
when I go out it sits off my face so it
isn't very irritating but it does still
trap moisture especially when I'm
teaching and talking a lot so my biggest
skin concerns now are more with
irritated skin skin texture and
superficial clogged pores my skin is
oily and dehydration prone I prefer not
to layer too many products yep still the
case too many steps gets confusing and
heavy and increases the chances of the
products interacting and clumping up or
irritating my skin and it takes longer
than I can handle still correct after
cleansing I like to use less than four
products I think the average has
actually gone down a bit since then I
think I generally use two or three I
think my average is more like one or two
now part of this is also because I
switched to more multifunctional
products that can take the place of two
or three products I don't like things
that are unpleasant to use even if
they're more effective I like to enjoy
my skincare routine I favor products
with convenient packaging and easy
application over things that I'm a pain
to use still true I also like Pleasant
textures and scents yes I think my
preferences for skin care are pretty
solidly set now and I think that does
come with just getting older and being
less money poor but more time poor and
energy poor I also got diagnosed with
ADHD and that's part of why I find it
difficult to stick to routines if
there's bad textures or weird scents or
fiddly packaging they're all just like
giant barriers to me using a product
just because I don't regularly use a
product I've loved in the past doesn't
mean I no longer recommend it sometimes
products just fall by the wayside as a
similar product has replaced it and I
haven't felt the need to repurchase it
sometimes I switch to a different
product and forgotten how good it was
and then later on I ReDiscover it and go
on a rave I think that is going to
happen in this video yeah and I just try
so many products I have a bad memory I
just forget about things if I put them
away plus I think I've been in the
process of slowly replacing single
function products with more
multifunctional ones or products with
nicer textures or packaging or whatever
I've tried so many products now in every
category there's probably at least three
or four products that are all really
great so which one I've been using at a
particular time might be something super
trivial like this fits in my bathroom
cabinet better so this is going to be
more like a snapshot of what I'm
currently using rather than my favorite
products of all time or even my favorite
products currently so the first step of
my routine which is like the same as
everyone probably is cleansing last year
I cleansed with an oil cleanser then a
gentle foaming cleanser I shower at
night so I step into the shower with oil
cleanse on my face then just step into
the shower for the foaming cleanser
that's still pretty much my routine even
during lockdown this has changed a bit I
mostly shower in the morning or
afternoon now so my hair can air dry as
much as possible before I go to sleep
because less effort I try to wear as
little makeup as possible if I'm going
to be wearing a mask which is most of
the time that I go out and that's to
reduce breakouts and also so I can keep
my mask less gross so that means I only
really use cleansing balms after filming
when I have a full proper face of makeup
probably about once a week this is the
cleansing balm I've been using it is
that then I met you living cleansing
balm I still love this it's still my top
cleansing balm of all time also a
disclaimer almost all the products I'll
be mentioning are PR samples which are
products that I've been sent with no
obligation to talk about them I get sent
a lot more products than I can try out
and almost all the brands that I like
and would buy offer to send me products
it's just how Beauty marketing works at
the moment the other cleansing balm I've
been using is the ordinary squalene
cleanser this is still my top budget
friendly recommendation but I haven't
used it in a while because I've been
trying out so many other cleansing balms
I have actually found a few more to join
then I Met You in My Favorites the alpha
H cleansing balm and the Crave beauty
makeup rewind both of these smell nice
and are really just a joy to use I have
a pretty strong preference for lightly
fragrance products over strongly
fragrance and also unfragranced I think
this might be technically unfragrance
but whatever raw materials they've used
smell really nice I've been using the
then I met you soothing tea cleansing
gels the Neutrogena Ultra Gentle daily
cleanser the bio Essence Firewater
micellar water I haven't really been
consistently using any specific wash off
cleansers lately here are the ones I've
been using if you're curious The Geek
and gorgeous jelly Joker cleanser this
is really nice for a non-foaming
cleanser really gentle but I think I
just need a little fragrance and a
cleanser to really love it this is the
ionic centella bubble cleansing foam I
really like their cell phone me pumps
this has like a bit of a herbal scent
it's really gentle and hydrating I've
also been using the CeraVe salicylic
acid cleanser this is really popular I
recommended it to my friend as like an
easy to find salicylic acid cleanser and
then I realized I hadn't actually tried
it it's fine it's not really giving me
that much of a difference on my skin and
it might just be because I'm already
using so much salicylic acid so I use
these foaming cleansers in the shower I
hate washing my face over the sink I've
talked about this before I hate how the
water goes everywhere and I have to wipe
it down afterwards I hate how it runs
down my arms so because of how my shower
routines change that means that I've
actually been using micellar water a lot
so the biogeoma sensor biomycella water
is my favorite I think I've gone through
maybe three bottles and this one is half
done I've raved about this a whole bunch
before so pretty much any time I'm
washing my face outside of the shower
this is it and I end up using this
probably most nights you don't have to
rinse it afterwards it was specifically
designed for people who are in places
where the tap water is not good for
their skin for makeup removal I've been
using this which is new it's the
bioderma two-phase sensor bio eye makeup
remover a little bit disappointingly the
water face isn't exactly the same as the
standard micellar water for both of
these I use reusable cotton rounds
there's the Velvet sort of texture ones
for the eyes and I use a cherry cloth
texture for my face I love how soft
these are compared to the Disposable
rounds I was using before and I just
chucked them into a mesh bag and then
put them in the laundry I'm still using
the bamboo ones that talked about before
and it's got this like handy tag to clip
for drying I've also started using the
medicate ones a lot more and I love
these because one side is Cherry cloth
and the other side is Velvet so I can
just use one for both my eyes and my
face and then Chuck it in the wash
whereas with the double-sided ones I
feel like I need to use it over a few
nights I've also tried these Garnier
ones but I don't like them as much
they're like a bit fluffy and the two
sides separate a bit more and yeah just
a personal preference and I don't think
this is that much cheaper than other
reusable rounds okay on to actives so I
use a three night cycle for my leave on
evening products tretinoa night Alpha
hydroxy acidine and vitamin C night I
still use a three night cycle
tretinoinite is always in there the
other true Knights have changed a bit
but generally there will be one harsh
exfoliating night and one gentle nicer
night recovery night last year I said
that my skin was still super sensitive
to tretinoin so thankfully it is a lot
less sensitive now I hardly ever get
massive of peeling I still only use it
every three days so yeah skin cycling is
trending but it isn't actually anything
new cycling is really just not using
every single product every night which
has always been the case if you followed
the instructions on a lot of skincare
products that said use twice a week so I
was doing it before 2019 I'm sure people
were doing it as long as skincare has
been around okay so I went down this
very very deep Rabbit Hole looking for
historical evidence of people's skin
cycling or just not using products every
single day and this is what I found
someone was using milk bars twice a week
so she was cycling her milk bars I guess
I even asked a archaeological expert who
has been digging into historical skin
care and she found that in ancient times
people tended to talk about products
that maybe you wouldn't use every day
because they were quite harsh but there
wasn't any actual written evidence of
how frequently people use them but yeah
so that was a good six hours and I
thought I would record this so I haven't
just completely wasted six hours with
nothing to show for it so yeah six hours
with the official skin cycle it
recommends one night for exfoliating
then one night for retinoids and then
two nights for hydration and soothing I
was doing something similar but with
retinoids as the first night then
exfoliation and then one rest night I
actually think most people could work up
to using a retinoid every night or every
other night even with my three night
cycle I felt like I wasn't using
retinoids enough most of the studies on
the benefits of retinoids use nightly
use there are a few where retinoids were
used every second night and then maybe
two studies where retinoids were used
twice a week or even once a week and
from the studies that looked at
frequency of use it seems like that the
more you use them the more benefits you
get the reason I wasn't using them as
often was because of that irritation and
flaking and I found that my skin was
most irritated two nights after using
tretinoin so that's why exfoliation was
on the other night to avoid that
stinging so I was after comfortably
using it every third night and then the
supply chain crisis hit so I didn't
actually have treasure known for about
six months so I tried out a lot of other
retinoid products instead and these ones
were my favorites the Medicaid Crystal
rationale this is my favorite rationale
product I've been seeing more retinoid
on the market and a lot of other
rationale products are really bright
yellow which like they'll still work but
it's just a bit off-putting because you
can actually see it on your skin or at
least I could
of the newer yellow ones this one was
probably my favorite the Trini rationale
niacinamide serum if you're looking for
a budget friendly rationale The Geek and
gorgeous A-game is the most
budget-friendly one I've seen I feel
like it doesn't really make my skin look
as nice as the other rationale products
and I think that's because it's just got
less supporting ingredients but this is
a good option if you just want to try a
rationale and yeah you don't want to
spend too much money I also really like
night shift from stratia this has
encapsulated rational and I did a
sponsored Instagram post explaining why
it was good so it's more stable and more
gentle they have studies on the raw
encapsulated rational ingredient that
they used as well as on the finished
product so I really like this it's got a
really moisturizing base and it just
works really well it's like an
all-in-one retinol product I also really
like the Paula's Choice point three
percent retinol and two percent
percussial this is again another really
good all-in-one product Paula's Choice
like to jam in all of the supporting
ingredients into their products which is
really good if you like to have one step
so this one has peptides vitamin C skin
soothing ingredients antioxidants I
think if I wanted like a really really
simple routine I could even just use
this every night here is another
all-in-one product the StriVectin Super
C rational this one has vitamin A B and
C and so again it's just like a
no-brainer sort of product where you
don't have to think too hard and you
still get like three actors without
worrying about layering and how much to
use and all of that you just slap one
thing on the only thing I don't like
about this is that it isn't a dropper
bottle and yeah dropper bottles are just
a little bit more effort for me to use
again like the reasons I use the product
are just so trivial a lot of the time so
after all of that I am back to working
my way up slowly with treasure Nolan and
I'm being a bit more cautious because of
all that mask irritation I've been
getting so I've been using those like
cosmetic retinoid products where my
Skin's too irritated to rest using this
this little tube of fire so the random
peeling from this and The Mask
irritation has also thrown my cycle out
of wax so it's sort of been like a
transition phase from that three night
regular cycle to something different I
guess ideally where I'm trying to get to
is using a retinoid product every second
night so here are the moisturizers I
tend to use the most the lineage cream
skin toner and moisturizer the Jordan
Samuel skin performance cream bioderma
sensor bio light Dr Dennis gross's
stress repair face cream for mixing with
treasure known I've been trying a few
different things but my solid Mainstay
is the larage per se psychoplas bomb
it's my go-to soothing cream so I figure
it has one of the best chances of
stopping all the flaking even though it
couldn't really save me from that half a
p of freshly open tretinoin they've
reformulated it to the B5 plus I picked
this up in Europe I'm still trying it
out but so far it seems to be working
pretty much just as well I've been
trying out a lot of really bougie moist
slightly that have been sent I've been
curious about fancy moisturizers for a
while and since my skin has been so
irritated I've been trying out creams
with lots of actors rather than trying
out serums because it just seems a bit
safer so some of the ones um the
biologic creme ISO placenta that then I
met you renewing Rich beauty cream which
has ginseng in it the solar Sue
essential Comfort firming cream this is
like a fitty snail's favorite brand that
I've been influenced by Jude talks about
this all the time so yeah I thought I'd
try some of their products there's also
the Emma lewisham Supernatural cream
which I really like and the Augustine
Espada cream which I think I just keep
seeing in lots of beauty magazines these
creams do seem to do more than cheaper
moisturizers but I haven't really made
up my mind about them yet I'm not
entirely sure that you couldn't get a
similar effect more cheaply with a serum
plus a moisturizer so to me they seem
like a nice treat yourself sort of
product or if you're in my situation
where you just want one thing that just
has everything in it and it's like
relatively safe and gentle on your skin
but I still need to test them out more
before I really make up my mind if my
Skin's too flaky or irritated I use Kate
Ryan's Total Nutrition Night Repair
complex instead I tend to use this a lot
on nights before I want my skin to look
really good this is still my favorite
cream to reliably give me this effect
but some of those fancy moisturizers
I've been using seem to do that too and
the textures are just a lot nicer as
much as I love this and I've Loved this
for a really long time it does have like
a bit of a gluey texture that makes it a
bit hard to spread and I think I've been
noticing it a bit more because of that
skin irritation so now I tend to mix
this with something else and yeah that's
just an extra step which makes me less
likely to pick this up so no two of my
cycle is Alpha hydroxy acid night and I
said that I still find that I get some
whiteheads if I don't use hydroxy acid
exfoliants regularly that's still the
case now this is especially important if
I'm trying out sunscreens yes that is
still true sunscreen still clogged the
crap out of my pores two percent BHA
liquid still love it still use it I'm
still going with this we're basically
married now we're celebrating our what
13th anniversary
this is my default exfoliant for
exfoliation night it just works so well
on my skin to make it smoother and clear
out my pores and just also refine that
texture it probably won't work for
everyone but I think it's a pretty nice
option for people who have oilier skin
and big pores I talk more about
different exfoliants and how to add them
to your routine in my free exfoliation
guide so download that if you haven't
already so back then my high strength
one was ultraceuticals Ultra brightening
serum that is still in my stash I still
use it here it is this is still on my
bedside table I use it a lot less now
usually only when I go to bed and I
realize I forgot to put on an exfoliant
I should have really just moved this to
the bathroom but then I wouldn't have
like an emergency exfoliant but there's
people that are dying I've started using
more p50 lotion which I bought when I
was in Paris I still like this but I
haven't actually used it for a long time
because I started on the p50 pigment 400
version that's what's recommended for
people with es agent skin that's pretty
to hyperpigmentation but I found that it
was like a bit weak on my skin probably
because I've been using exfoliants for
so long so I think I just forgot to go
back to the p50 another acid product
I've been using a bit more is Dr Dennis
gross's Alpha Beta Universal daily peel
and this I think it's mostly just
convenience I actually just got back
from a holiday and yeah I took these
along because they are just so so
convenient on night 3 I found that
recently I haven't really been using
vitamin C and I think that's because I
haven't really had that much
post-inflammatory hyperpigmentation that
is the case now as well and I can't
really complain but vitamin C is a
really good ingredient for other reasons
as well I used to use it at night
because I didn't like layering anything
under sunscreen it was too sticky but
now that I don't wear sunscreen most
days because of how I live in a cave I
tend to use vitamin C in the morning
when I remember which is like twice a
week I should really like put it on top
of my toothbrush or something the one I
like the most is the skinceutical
silamon CF this is like the classic
cferylic formula but it was designed for
oily skin so the vitamin E has been
replaced with silamarin the silamarin is
less thick and oily compared to vitamin
E and so it's meant to clog your pores
less and just yeah be less oily for oily
skin one thing I really like about this
is that instead of smelling like hot dog
water which is like that classic vitamin
C serum with ferulic acid smell this
actually smells sort of like those
capico coffee lollies it's got this sort
of like caramel coffee scent which is a
lot nicer than that classic hot dog
scent and the other option for vitamin C
is just using it in another product so
this one also has vitamin C and also the
Polish Choice rationale also has vitamin
C in it so yeah one less thing for me to
remember with my terrible Goldfish
Memory so on my third night instead of
vitamin C A lot of the time now I will
use these peculature reface pads from
indeed Labs La clinica's Essentials
hydrating and healing serum I've
actually stopped using both of those I
really love of the Paula's Choice 10
nice and in my booster I don't know why
I stopped using it I think I just forgot
about it maybe I should go back to it I
think also a lot of the products I've
been testing tend to have niacinamide in
them nowadays so maybe I think I just
sort of feel like I'm getting enough
niacinamide but I'm definitely not
getting 10 so I've actually gotten back
into using niacinamide for my break
nights and yeah maybe it's because I've
been using more Western Products
recently that aren't as niacinamide
heavy as Asian products so the ones I've
been using the TBH rebound this is a
nice in my serum that was developed as a
collaboration with my friend Hannah
English who is a pharmaceutical science
she is on Instagram as Miss Hannah e
this has a really long list of other
nice ingredients as well like humectants
ceramides Alan Towing centella panthenol
so it's really good for like an active
recovery night it's a similar sort of
idea to that La Clinica serum that I
talked about
um and it's just really pretty it's in
this like pretty gradient Palm and it
has a really nice texture this yeah my
skin just really likes this it's just
super super benign there's also the then
I met you giving Essence which is a nice
and wide product that also has a bunch
of fermented ingredients so spot
treatments depending on what spots I
have I used Paula's Choice four percent
BHA hydrocolloid bandages micro needle
patches I ran out of the four percent
BHA and I didn't really like the texture
and I don't get pimples that often so
usually I just use a micro needle patch
overnight and the two percent BHA during
the day I've gotten lazy and my skin
hasn't been feeling that dehydrated I
think because a lot of my products now
have lots of humectants in them yeah I
don't really use masks at all really
although I guess when I have really
irritated skin I'll use a really thick
layer of La Roche passe cycloplast
overnight as like a mask but yeah it's
like really just a thing that I slap on
when I feel like I can't really slap
anything else on exfoliation ketchup now
I actually only use exfoliate for this a
lot of the time is actually an add-on
rather than
a substitute physical exfoliation one to
two times a week I still do that and I
am still using a peeling gel the peeling
gel I'm using is ginfu's pineapple
peeling gel amazingly I don't think that
has actually changed I'm still using
exfoliate I forgot to put it inside the
Box because it is in my shower I
literally used it last night
um it is the best in shower exfoliating
mask I've ever tried with peeling gels I
ran out of the skin food so I'm now
trying out this mission one which works
quite well in general I found that
cellulose peeling gels work a lot better
than acrylates ones they work better on
wet skin which is when I use them the
acrylates ones work better on dry skin
if you use an acrylates one on wet skin
sometimes you end up with like bits on
your face that kind of feel weird and
tacky and filmy so watch out for that I
don't think it's with all products but
cellulose is just a safer bet for in the
shower so things I've added to my
routines since last time I've added a
microcurrent device this is the furry
bear I did a sponsorship with them I
also have a new face that I sometimes
use as well and I've been playing around
with them and trying to compare them I
just got back from holidays and I'm
trying to get back into using this but I
tend to be a bit sporadic because I'm
just bad at using things daily and every
night I'm a night owl and I tend to put
off my night routine until as late as
possible and then I have to try to cram
it in and so I'm probably going to try
using this in the middle of the day
instead I also realized last time I
forgot to talk about lip balm and yeah
so the lip balm I've been using the most
is the dermal therapy lip balm this
brand is an Australian brand it is six
dollars and it is just really good it is
the best lip balm I've ever tried
they've got a bunch of different flavors
some of them have Menthol so if you
don't like Menthol I don't like Menthol
um watch out for that but they have two
flavors that definitely don't probably
more
um Manuka honey and pawpaw both of them
are Menthol free and yeah they just work
really well a lot of people who are on
um row Accutane use this and yeah it
works really well for super dried out
lips which might not this one from skin
fix also works quite well as well it's
probably the next best one after this
and yeah I don't love their clean
marketing but this is actually quite a
good product so looking back I guess the
biggest changes from 2020 to 2022 my
Skin's gotten more sensitive and prone
to irritation but I also have less acne
so my routine has wished to more focus
on soothing products and gentler
retinoids and that's also because I ran
out of tretinoin my cleansing has also
changed a bit because of when I shower
but conceptually my routine is still
pretty much the same routine it works
really well for my skin it might not
work for yours I am planning to ramp up
the retinoid use so we'll see how that
goes with actually changing my cycle for
the first time after three years ish so
we'll revisit how that went next year
like subscribe notification Bell for
more nerdy Beauty talk you can follow me
on Instagram and Tick Tock and more
videos should be popping up around me if
you want to watch more